mitterrand la décentralisation facteur
de cohésion nationale les dix mesures
fiscales soumise aux députés obstacle
inattendu pour le numéro un du pc
polonais madame thatcher toujours pour
l' intransigeance et à messieurs bonsoir
quand des élus provinciaux pour la
plupart se retrouvent à paris autour
d'une table en conseil des ministres
pour parler des poids respectifs de
l'état et des régions
deux thèses s'affrontent en général
vieille comme la france d'ailleurs celle
des jacobins centralisateur et puis
celle des girondins qui sont à eux
décentralisateur et dès aujourd'hui
c'est la seconde qui l'a emporté pour le
ministre veut même enfer la grande
affaire du septennat est le chef de
l'état de déclarer ce matin la france a
eu besoin d'un pouvoir centralisé fort
pour ce faire elle a besoin d'un pouvoir
décentralisé pour ne pas défaire le
conseil a donc adopté ce projet de loi
qui s'il est adopté transformera
profondément paul amar deux siècles
d'habitude effectivement napoléon c'est
fini et son héritage va sans doute volé
en éclats et d'abord la fonction de
préfet que l'empereur avait créé et qui
va disparaître ne dira plus préfet mais
commissaire de la république c'est un
titre assez sévère commissaire ça
pourrait donner l'impression qu'ils
pourraient jouer un rôle prêté policiers
wii ou autoritaire au sein du
département de la région de la commune
vient pas du tout c'est un titre assez
trompeur le commissaire de la république
aura une fonction beaucoup plus effacé
beaucoup plus discrète que son
prédécesseur le préfet le pouvoir
exécutif que les préfets détenait donc
dans ces régions où ces départements va
désormais leur échapper et va passer
solennellement entre les mains de l'élu
local le maire le président du conseil
général ou du conseil régional qui sera
en quelque sorte les patrons de leur
commune et qui rompent pourront prendre
leur décision sans demander
systématiquement la bénédiction du
commissaire de la république ils
pourront construire une crèche une école
mais sans demander l'autorisation mais
ça veut dire qu'à l'époque fonctions
supprimés
non pas du tout les contrôles préalables
a priori qui sont effectués actuellement
sont supprimés en france y aura toujours
un contrôle mais qui se fera à
postériori autrement dit si le
représentant de l'état le commissaire de
la république
si vous désapprouvent une décision prise
par l'élu local il pourra faire appel au
tribunal administratif ou à la chambre
régionale des comptes c'est une
innovation en aucun cas il ne décidera
c'est le magistrat désormais jouera le
rôle d arbitre parle évidemment un
projet de loi cette importance peut pas
faire l'unanimité
non et l'opposition craint les
conséquences de cette liberté donnée aux
élus locaux
olivier guichard lui-même redoutent que
l'unité nationale ne soit menacée et
souhaite que le couple c'est son
expression je le cite que le couple état
collectivités locales ne soient pas
dissocier à françois mitterrand est
parfaitement conscient de ce risque
il souhaite lui aussi préservé d'une
tirer seul vous l'avez rappelé mais ils
adoptent la démarche inverse c'est
précisément pour préserver cette unité
cette cohésion qu'il faut être je
traduis sa pensée plus libérale avec
l'autre partenaire en l'occurrence les
collectivités locales autrement dit pour
lui le plus sûr moyen de garder son
partenaire c'est de ne pas être
autoritaire mais libéral seulement voilà
ce partenaire pourrait avoir la
tentation un peu grisé par cette liberté
de se rebeller même contre l'état s'il
pourrait avoir cette tentation
mais il sait que de toute façon même si
l'état se montre libéral serait un jour
freiner ou sanctionnés dans ses
ambitions ses appétits par les lecteurs
tout simplement car pour mieux
comprendre la portée pratique de cette
révolution dans les moeurs à la
république nous avons choisi un exemple
il nous paraît caractéristiques de
heurts entre élus locaux et pouvoir
central l affaire du terrain à auch à
grenoble une ancienne caserne libéré il
y a huit ans et pour laquelle la ville
et l'état avait des vues très
dissemblables c'est à reportage de
lorraine accusait neuf hectares dans le
centre résidentiel de grenoble grenoble
175 mille habitants 2500 demandes de
logements sociaux en attente
les populations ont pu s'exprimer dans
la presse dans les unions de quartier à
la mairie sur l'utilisation du terrain
les riverains veulent qu'un parc les
autres des logements avec espaces verts
plusieurs maquettes sont exposées tout
le monde pouvait donner son avis adam
titeux lui comme moi je crois qu'ils en
ont tenu compte parce que dans certaines
il ya eu certaines observations par
exemple au point de vue de la densité de
logements de la répartition des
logements sur le terrain il j'ai
l'impression très nette après les
maquettes qui ont été déposées contre
lui contre deux observations fin 81
projets d'environ 400 logements sociaux
est retenue avec crèche maternelle
équipements sportifs maison pour le
troisième âge le préfet saisi par une
association minoritaires opposées au
projet s'en réfère au ministre de
l'environnement de l'époque il décide
200 logements
sinon pas de subventions beaucoup de
bois j'étais scandalisé nizon par le
fait que finalement la décision vienne
de paris alors que on avait discuté ici
est infléchi à l' usage de ce terrain et
que finalement ce qui ressortait
majoritairement de ce qu'ils avaient des
contacts afin d'inciter les gens à
exprimer a été complètement balayées par
la décision du ministre un peu pourtant
l'implantation de logements sociaux
centre ville étaient encouragés par le
gouvernement depuis 78 ce refus c'est la
manifestation d'une super tutelle c'est
le fait du prince 10 des élus d'autant
que le projet était conforme au
règlement d'urbanisme les normes
d'urbanisme ont été respectées sur auch
puisqu'il était possible de construire
800 logements environ sur ce terrain
alors que le projet n'en comporte que
le 16 juin dernier le préfet délivre le
permis de construire le projet est
débloquée supprimer la tutelle
préfectorale sur le maire s'est créé un
nouvel état d'esprit un débat local doit
rester la sphère de la collectivité
locale
nous devons décider sur place et vêpres
effet l'administration du département
comme de l'état est là pour aider les
habitants à régler leurs problèmes à
travers leurs conseils ministre
du côté des électeurs on est bien sûr
pour cette décentralisation mais
certains aimerait bien disposer d'un
contrepoids au pouvoir du conseil
municipal nos élus ont été 6 ans et pas
forcément sur les projets que nous
propose actuellement et je pense que
quand s'engage d'eupen façon l'avenir de
la ville un pur quand même des décennies
je pense qu'effectivement la population
a droit à demander un référendum
populaire le candidat mitterrand n'y
était pas opposé à condition d'en
définir les modalités
ce référendum populaire sera-t-il un des
éléments de la nouvelle citoyenneté
alors en principe c'est donc ce qu'on ne
devrait plus voir si ce projet de loi
sur la décentralisation est adoptée à un
projet qualifié par gaston defferre de
véritable révolution pacifique au cours
du même conseil des ministres on a
appris la nomination d'un nouveau
directeur de l'administration
pénitentiaire
yvan akin jusqu'à leur directeur de
l'éducation surveillée
la nomination d'un nouveau préfet de
police de paris jean perrier qui était
préfet de bretagne
et puis la convocation de l'assemblée
nationale en session extraordinaire à
partir de vendredi prochain on y
débattra d'un texte relatif à la cour de
cassation d'un projet de loi qui porte
sur le prix unique des livres et donc de
la décentralisation
pour l'heure cette assemblée nationale
est en train de se prononcer sur le
collectif budgétaire
en gros c'est une rallonge destiné à
financer les actions décidées en faveur
de l'emploi et des entreprises
christian mary mono nous disent qu'il ya
dedans le montant du collectif
budgétaire s'élève à 7 milliards 710
millions de francs
les dépenses elles concernent l'emploi
les agriculteurs les anciens combattants
les jeunes et l'aide aux entreprises des
créations d'emplois sont prévues dans le
secteur privé en développant le
troisième pacte pour l'emploi des jeunes
la formation professionnelle
coût de l'opération 2 milliards de
francs dans le secteur public 33 milles
550 emplois seront créés pour 80
l'incidence budgétaire ne dépassera pas
800 millions de francs
le lancement de 58 logements sociaux
sera financé pour un montant de 200
millions de francs en 81
l'aide aux entreprises par des prêts du
fonds de développement add aide aux
industries un morceau important
puisqu'il rapportera 3 milliards et demi
de francs et cela afin de favoriser une
nouvelle politique industrielle les
économies d'énergie et la valorisation
de la recherche
enfin les jeunes agriculteurs les
internes des lycées et les anciens
combattants se partageront le reste des
dépenses
côté recettes le montant total est aussi
2,7 milliards 610 millions de francs qui
résulte de cette mesure fiscale
les 108 mille contribuables aisés qui
s'acquittent d'un impôt supérieur à 100
mille francs par an perron une surtaxe
de 25 % le rendement attendu est fixé à
3 milliards 400 millions de francs soit
la moitié des recettes nouvelles
les compagnies pétrolières qui exploite
un gisement france se verront leurs
profits tax et principales victimes
elf et esso recettes 1 milliard de
francs les profits bancaires apportons
également un milliard de francs les
frais généraux c'est à dire les petits
cadeaux des chefs d'entreprises seront
imposées les voitures les logements de
fonction rendement escompté 1 milliard
200 millions de francs les hôtels de
luxe supporteront le taux de plus fort
de la tva 160 millions de francs
sans oublier les gros bateaux 50
millions de francs une fois ajouté est
ce dispositif une augmentation de la
taxe intérieure sur les carburants faut
donc s'attendre à une prochaine hausse
de l'essence
et puis une taxation des bénéfices des
entreprises de travail par intérim aura
aussi peut-être qui a ajouté cet
amendement proposé par le rapporteur la
commission des finances question pire
est à un moment qui vise à supprimer les
avantages fiscaux jusqu alors attaché
aux donations partages christian pierret
dit pourquoi il a fait cette proposition
nous avons constaté que donation-partage
sont particulièrement répandue pour les
gros patrimoines et nous avons constaté
aussi que depuis quelques semaines se
multiplient ces donations partages ou
quoi d'où la question mais c'est sans
doute parce que le gouvernement a
annoncé et c'était dans le programme de
françois mitterrand président de la
république et dans le programme du
gouvernement mauroy pierre mauroy l'a
rappelé il ya quelques jours nous avons
annoncé la création d'un impôt sur les
grandes fortunes
par conséquent les gens qui possèdent
aujourd'hui des grandes fortunes cherche
à se prémunir
contre le futur impôt qui sera
probablement voté à l'automne en
divisant d'ores et déjà à leur fortune
entre leurs héritiers d'où là le fait
qu'ils peuvent profiter de l'ancien
donation partage qui était moins cher si
vous voulez comme droits de succession
mais pour qu'il soit bien car rappelle
que cette donation partage permettait de
partager de son vivant l'essentiel de
son patrimoine sans avoir à payer des
droits de succession très important
alors qu'est-ce que cela va changer à
nos terres nous disent qu'ils en pensent
personnellement je pense que l'on
pourrait par exemple dire que la
réduction des droits en matière de
donation partage pour était maintenue
par exemple pour une part revenant à
chaque héritier de 500 mille francs et
qu'au contraire la réduction des droits
en matière de donation partage pourrait
être supprimée au delà d'une certaine
somme recueillie car regain d'intérêt
pour cette nation en partage c'était une
façon d'éviter l'impôt sur la fortune de
fractionner le patrimoine
écoutez véritablement dans les
conversations que j'ai eues mois alors
en tant que notaire individuel avec mes
clients qui sont venu me consulter ces
temps derniers pour des donations
partages l'aspect impôt sur le capital
n'a pas été évoquée ce qui a été
essentiellement évoqué ce que je ressens
moi au travers des conversations de vue
mais cette fois en tant que notaire à
titre individuel si vous voulez c'est
l'inquiétude devant informer ossements
des droits sociaux les députés
poursuivront la discussion sur le
collectif budgétaire demain mais tout à
l'heure en début d'après-midi un vif
incident au palais bourbon le président
du groupe rpr dans un rappel au
règlement venait protester contre la
nouvelle procédure des questions au
gouvernement qui accorde at il dit deux
fois plus de temps au groupe socialiste
qu'aux trois autres groupes alors
écoutez bien cool la baie et ce qui s'en
est suivi c'est donc si cette procédure
devait être mise en place nous est
imposé
une preuve nouvelle d'un certain esprit
d'intolérance qui tend à s'instaurer
dans cette maison et qui comptera ce et
qui contrastent manifestement avec
l'état de grâce et des déclarations
extérieur nous tenions à le souligner
franches par marca monsieur l'abbé que
je ne sais pas si fins heures cela au
titre de l'état de grâce mais il vient
déjà de pouvoir prononcer un discours
monsieur jacques monsieur jointe à
monsieur georges monsieur jean cras
seule la parole ajoutant leurs collègues
cela dit si monsieur l'abbé veut
remettre en cause la répartition
d'aujourd'hui alors qu'il n'a pas cru
devoir remettre en cause celle de la
répartition du temps de parole pour les
questions orales de vendredi c'est son
affaire
j'ai la faiblesse de considérer que s'il
l'a pas remise en cause vendredi sais
pas s'il y avait moins de monde et que
s'il le fait aujourd'hui c'est pour
donner un écho
c'est une mauvaise réponse et là encore
c'est une mauvaise manière
et la semaine pense toutefois
l'opposition s'est doublée ces sols dans
vos dialogues
j'invite les membres de l'opposition à
participer aux travaux de l'assemblée
nationale voilà l'élément de position
n'ont pas cédé et c'est un vide qui sont
tous partis donc rpr comme edf alors
daniel brême qu'est ce qui s'est passé
après leur exploit
qu'est ce que vous venez de voir
quelques claquements de pupitres et non
le mot est révélateur du film à
d'irritation pour ne pas dire
d'exaspération qui rêvent régné entre
l'opposition qui s'est révélée puisqu'il
ya même eu une réunion rapide du groupe
communes et les socialistes alors dans
le découvrir la polémique s'est
poursuivie une bonne petite heure les
deux présidents de groupe rpr et udf
voulait être reçus sur leur part le
président mermaz est considéré qu' il
veut politiser jusqu aux éloges funèbres
ce qui nuisait au recueillement la
formule et de claude la paix et puis
quelques instants plus tard il ya une
face à face un peu tendu entre pierre
joxe et claude la paix le second
reprochant son premier d'être un
hypocrite en retirer ce mot dit monsieur
pierre joxe en faisant un pas en avant
ce que fit monsieur claude labbé qui
matin cependant que le
l'esprit d'ouverture des questions
d'actualité qui dominait dans le
précédent septennat et qui permettent à
chaque vous mais qui permettait à chaque
groupe d'avoir un quart d'heure et bien
été complètement altérée et il a rappelé
que les socialistes alors on avait
profité à quoi pierre joxe rétorqué je
ne mets pas en cause je cite la mauvaise
foi de l'opposition rappelez vous lors
de notre dernière réunion de président
de groupe
vous aviez accepté cette répartition des
temps de parole pour cette séance à quoi
évidemment claude labbé ont rétorqué en
disant que ce n'était pas vrai et on
court plusieurs pierre joxe a dit
écoutez nous avons jusqu'au mois
d'octobre pour trouver une solution
puisqu'il n'y aura pas d'autres
questions d'actualité dans les sessions
extraordinaires
il n'y en a pas nous essaierons de donc
de trouver une solution mais je propose
10 est il que les journalistes désormais
assiste à lons réunion fifa ya pas eu de
duel quand même temps a passé mais sur
un pré carré n'ont pas tout à fait
d'accord
merci daniel les chiffres du chômage
nous les connaissons depuis une heure
ils sont impressionnants un million huit
cent vingt-cinq mille 300 demandeurs
d'emploi en juin soit 1 7% de plus qu'au
mois de mai c'est un chiffre corrigé des
variations saisonnières levée de la
suspension des contrats d'armement
français vers la libye ainsi en a décidé
le quai d'orsay
cela permettra également l'exécution du
contrat passé entre libyens et elf
aquitaine pour l'attribution de permis
de recherche pétrolière
voilà qui nous amène à l'étranger avec
tout d'abord la situation pologne car
rien n'est clair au congrès du parti
ouvrier unifié
les congressistes ont eu du mal à se
mettre d'accord sur la désignation du
premier secrétaire et ils ont pu lire un
document qui met en cause
l'homme qui occupe ce poste aujourd'hui
c'est alice à scania gérard ce bague et
notre envoyé spécial sur place
l'élection de monsieur stanislas
kahniens comme premier secrétaire du
parti communiste polonais que l'on donné
comme certaines à l'ouverture paraît
maintenant rencontrer certaines
difficultés
en effet dans les couloirs du congrès un
document serait en train de circuler
contre monsieur cagna il s'agit d'une
accusation de monsieur gomulka ancien
secrétaire du parti communiste polonais
jusqu'en 1970
dans une lettre monsieur comme hulk à
qui réside à une vingtaine de km 2
varsovie affirme que monsieur cagna a
participé à la décision de faire
intervenir les forces de l'ordre et de
tirer sur les grévistes des ports de la
baltique en 1970 incidents qui avaient
fait plusieurs dizaines de morts causé
la chute de monsieur gomulka et
l'arrivée au pouvoir de monsieur direct
accusations extrêmement graves qui
jetterait donc une ombre sur la
personnalité de monsieur cagna et
expliquerait qu'encore le congrès n'est
pas désigné son nouveau premier
secrétaire
simple manoeuvre ou peut-être
manipulation de la presse que monsieur
cagnard réussira à déjouer ce qui
renforcera donc son pouvoir ou
accusation fondée voilà qui en tout cas
relance très sensiblement l'intérêt de
ce deuxième congrès du parti communiste
polonais et montre que la lutte pour le
pouvoir est encore loin d'être joué à
varsovie
deuxième point chaud dans le monde
d'irlande du nord avec tout d'abord un
attentat il ya deux heures dans un hôtel
de belfast le wellington park hôtel il
ya deux blessés
et puis cet après-midi les obsèques de
martine heures c'est le sixième
militants de l'ira être mort d'une grève
de la faim les obsèques impressionnante
regardez ces images aujourd'hui à
capable dans la région de belfast a donc
été enterrés martin larsson martin
larsson 6e détenus politiques de la
prison de maze à mourir à présent fait
la grève de la faim la grève pour que
soient reconnus aux prisonniers dira le
droit d'être considérés comme des
prisonniers politiques
martin orson a été enterré avec les
honneurs militaires du involontaire de
l'ira des soldats de l'armée secrète
masqués ont porté son cercueil jusqu'au
cimetière
c'est un autre membre de l'ira amat
d'evelyne g de 31 ans qui remplace
martin larsson mort avant-hier après 45
jours de jeunes matt d'evelyne qui comme
les autres détenus de la prison de maze
réclament une amélioration des
conditions de détention mais le
gouvernement britannique se refuse à
toute réforme tant que la grève de la
faim se poursuivra
l'ofce sont le ministre français des
relations extérieures a estimé que paris
n'avait pas à faire de déclaration sur
la situation de l'inter cela ne pourrait
qu'aggraver les choses at il dit par
ailleurs le gouvernement irlandais celui
de dublin n'ont qu'a lancé un appel à
ronald reagan pour qu'il intervienne
directement auprès de madame ce match
comme ça de choc qui a d'autres
problèmes sur les bras depuis quelques
jours cette flambée de violence soudaine
et aveugle
la nuit dernière pas d'incident mais une
vague d'arrestations jean-marc il use
fait le point politique il serait faux
de croire que l'angleterre vite en
l'état siègent comme cet imprimeur de
brixton
mais ce qui a changé après deux jours
d'émeutes dans les grandes villes c'est
que personne ici ne peut plus dire que
dans les faubourgs pauvres de
l'angleterre
la violence qu'elle soit l'origine
raciale criminelle au surtout social
n'est qu'un phénomène saisonnier
on peut aussi vite oublié alors pour
madame thatcher il faut d'abord rétablir
la loi et l'ordre le chômage
on verra ensuite est la priorité des
priorités c'est de mieux armer la police
et le muscle et la justice je
préférerais que nous policiers
continuaient à patrouiller pacifiquement
comme d'habitude h
vous savez la violence engendre la
violence à une faudrait mieux traiter
les problèmes de fond avant de renforcer
la police mais aujourd'hui l'heure n'est
pas aux problèmes de fond le
gouvernement fait passer l'aide à
l'emploi des jeunes
après la restauration de l'ordre
remarque sèchement le financial times
journal des milieux d'affaires
c'est vrai l'obsession de la presse
conservatrice c'est un peu aujourd'hui
le cannois aux symboles contester des
moyens dont dispose la police en irlande
du nord avec le gaz lacrymogènes et les
balles en plastique un arsenal dont le
ministre de l'intérieur après bien des
réticences mais sous la pression des
parlementaires conservateurs veut
maintenant doté la police
une police désormais au centre du débat
seuls en europe à ne pas disposer de
brigades anti émeutes
elle a mal résisté au choc 520 blessés
en deux jours
un chiffre qui contraint les
parlementaires travaillistes art viser
un instant leurs critiques de la
politique économique de madame thatcher
oui à une police mieux équipée du style
mais nous ne voulons pas de crs à la
française je cite ou de loi anti
casseurs
reste que ce matin à brixton au 54 rue
ottawa après une perquisition de la
police cette nuit
les jamaïcains accusaient les policiers
de jouer les casseurs quant à lui entré
chez moi la police a tout mis en pièces
dans mon appartement je ne suis pas un
malfaiteur dans la vie j'essaie
d'étudier la musique
honnêtement et voilà le résultat
méfiance née en visite et c'est cela le
calme relatif des faubourgs
oui beaucoup de britanniques craignent
que les rues de brixton ou d'ailleurs ne
présente demain l'aspect quotidien de
celles de belfast où de l'ondaine déry
mais beaucoup aussi craignent une
réforme trop hâtive de leur justice de
leurs polices compromettent l'avenir de
leurs traditions démocratiques
un rude débat en perspective demain au
parlement
nous parlions de la pologne et bien à
l'instant selon la fpp monsieur rakowski
et jusqu'à leur vice premier ministre
aurait pris une option sérieuse pour le
poste de premier secrétaire triste
monsieur kahniens en prononçant un
discours 13 très réformiste et applaudi
par les 2000 délégués de ce congrès et
puis une dernière dépêche également
françois mitterrand adressé un message
de prompt rétablissement au pape jean
paul ii au moment où s'ouvrent bien sûr
le congrès eucharistique de lourdes
auquel le pape aurait dû se rendre en
bref sachez encore que mes narines begin
a été officiellement chargé de former le
cabinet israélien et que des tirs de
roquettes se sont abattues cet après
midi sur le nord d'israël quatre blessés
dit tel aviv hier les raids israéliens
sur le sud liban avait fait 19 morts et
28 blessés
enfin un attentat à bangui hier soir
dans un cinéma trois morts dont un
français et 24 blessés dont trois
coopérants français
voilà ce que l'on dit à l'ambassade de
france en centrafrique on y ajoute que
la situation est calme la situation là
l'enjeu n'a pas été revendiqué et on
ignore pour l'instant l'identité des
victimes
sport maintenant avec tout d'abord cette
revanche de bernard hinault peut-être un
petit peu agacé par les critiques qui
l'accusé de mener le tour de france en
père de famille sans coup d'éclat et dès
aujourd'hui la gagner et bien gai
et c'était la dernière des grandes
étapes de montagne richard dion c'est en
effet le hino dominateur que l'on a vu
aujourd'hui entre bourg d'oisans et le
pleynet de son style énergique il a
éparpillé tout le monde dans la deuxième
grande étape des alpes
ceux qui ont cru voir in our difficulté
hier dans la montée de l'alpe d'huez
n'ont rien compris a lancé guy mars
matin et c'est peut-être pour répondre
personnellement kino a réalisé son
récital tout seul cet après midi certes
l'opposition n'a jamais été aussi faible
exception faite d'alban tous et faire
valoir van impe zoetemelk de munich sont
d'âge canonique mais tout de même on ne
gagne pas une étape de montagne en
roulant en cyclotouriste pour une fois
bernaudeau l'ex amie dino à justifier ça
fait une réputation il a été le seul à
rester à portée du maillot jaune le
management mode dit souvent hinault il
n'empêche que c'est avec panache qu'il
s'est hissé au pleynet car il a fait
plus que le nécessaire pour gagner
aujourd'hui
ce soir il compte douze minutes et 12
secondes sur van impe deuxième 13 22 /
alban troisième bernaudeau arrive 30
secondes après i know we know qui voit
plus que jamais la vie en jaune
seule une révolution ou un cataclysme
pourrait empêcher maintenant le breton
de rapporter son maillot à paris
bon pour le cataclysme on verra mais
tout à l'heure avec alain gillot-pétré
envoie à l'arrivée cette nuit à brest de
marc pajot et ses équipes est arrivé au
petit trot parce qu'il ya eu beaucoup de
vent les quatre hommes menée quand même
de battre leur record du monde traversée
de l'atlantique et ils ont reçu un
message manuscrit du chef de l'état je
tiens à vous féliciter pour votre
exploit dit françois mitterrand vous
avez superbement ouvert le défilé du 14
juillet football maintenant premier
match du tournoi de paris et dia
saint-etienne vient de perdre contre
l'eintracht de francfort 4 3 aux
penaltys cela veut dire qu'il y avait
match nul à la fin du temps
réglementaire les pronostics de pyatt
bresse pour le quarté de demain vous
allez le voir le 15
le 12 le 13 le 2 le 9 le 3 le 6 et le 8
création aujourd'hui d'un comité société
du personnel hors statut dans les
chaînes de télévision ils demandent
l'intégration immédiate de tous ceux qui
travaillent régulièrement pour ses
différentes sociétés
et puis la création d'emplois qui nous
permettent de ne plus faire appel aux
entreprises privées pour les
banlieusards parisiens je signale qu'il
ya actuellement un mouvement de grève
qui perturbe le trafic banlieue de la
gare des listes s'être pass culture
maintenant du côté des festivals et bien
chaque année on assiste à la floraison
de quelques 300 manifestations
théâtrales musicales chorégraphiques
dont les points forts portent les noms
vous le savez d'avignon d'orange d'aix
en provence ou de vaison-la-romaine
moins connus mais plein de charme et de
qualité artistique les festivals de
saint-bertrand-de-comminges et de sarlat
en péril
ce sont ceux là qui ont retenu
l'attention de georges b
au pied des pyrénées une sorte de mont
saint michel des terres
saint-bertrand-de-comminges 240
habitants dans ce petit village qui
reçoit en été plus de cent mille
visiteurs
certains viennent simplement pour
admirer la splendeur singulière de l'
architecture de la cathédrale d'autres
sont là pour assister au festival de
musique qui s'y déroule chaque année au
mois de juillet l'orgueil de cette
cathédrale qui ne manque pas de
richesses et cet orgue unique au monde
un orgue d'angle au buffet renaissance
récemment restaurée et dont joue pour
nous michel chapuis
non
lessard est une ville très ancienne
puisqu'elle a été créée par des moines
il ya un certain d'un grand nombre de
sièges vers le 11e et aussi curieux que
cela puisse paraître on dit qu'elle a
été créée sur un lac d'où viendrait le
nom sur laquelle un homme qui est devenu
sarlat ensuite
et puis c'est une ville qui a qui s'est
développée surtout au moyen-âge et qui
chose très curieuse avait dès le moyen
âge près de 8000 habitants alors
qu'aujourd'hui le x10 mini
pourquoi il n'y avait pas de moyens
d'accès comme aujourd'hui et bien c'est
peut-être une c'est à la fois un
problème sur le plan économique c'est
que sarlat est à l'écart des des routes
et que ça à la fois aux allé prendre un
point de vue économique mais que ça a
certainement contribué à conserver le
grand très grand nombre de vieux hôtels
dans sarlat qui vont
on est 13 14e au 18ème à sarlat du 20
juillet au 10 août un festival aussi
divers qu intéressant avec notamment le
grand magic circus qui joue le bourgeois
gentilhomme et le théâtre des campagnols
qui présente le bal un des meilleur
spectacle de l'année qui raconte sans
paroles mais en musique les moments de
notre passé les épisodes se succèdent
d'une décennie à l'autre on passe
allègrement des joies de la libération à
la découverte des cigarettes américaines
que les iai allons offrir généreusement
le spectacle du théâtre campagnols à
travers les musiques les modes
vestimentaires les attitudes les
cheminements de chacun des personnages
retrace des moments de l'histoire au
quotidien celle qui ne s'apprend pas
dans les écoles mais dans les mémoires
se souviennent avec émotion
voilà ces feux d'artifice nous amène
tout de suite à la météo alors tout de
suite
alain gillot-pétré h voit sa petite tête
il va faire beau ben trop mauvais dans
l'ensemble pour demain mais tout de même
au nord de la loire vous avez vu pour
les festivals pas de problème à beaucoup
de soleil mais au nord de la loire
des nuages d'été peut-être même
l'arrivée de pluies en fin d'après-midi
par le nord ouest les températures
d'aujourd'hui à 14 heures quand dire
elles sont toujours au nord de la loire
je reviens mais c'est pourtant la vérité
au sud toujours pas de problème mais au
nord en dessous des normes saisonnières
à 20 heures et à 20 heures qu'est ce que
je dis à 14 heures il faisait 20 degrés
à paris il devrait faire 25 en moyenne
donc nous sommes en dessous des normes
saisonnières la prévision pour demain
comme vous le voyez au sud de la loire
pas de problème quand je me répète du
soleil quasiment toute la journée un
petit peu drummond aquitaine qui se
lèveront dans la matinée ailleurs c'est
à dire au nord vous le voyez un temps
variable avec des éclaircies des
passages nuageux espérons que les
éclaircies prédomineront et puis en fin
d'après midi arrivée d'une zone humide
un tout petit peu plus fraîches avec
quelques pluies par le nord-ouest et
cette zone de pluie devraient en
principe traverser le pays du nord et du
nord-ouest au sud-est vendredi
enfin on en reparlera la prévision de
température maintenant toujours pareil
12 en or je vois pas très bien d'où zone
en 13-14 ans 12-13 oui tout cela est à
peu près normale pour le matin l'après
midi toujours pareil au nord de la loire
en dessous des normes aussi c'est très
bien enfin de notre film hybride agenda
pour demain demain jeudi 16 juillet les
heurts du soleil et l'amour est enfant
de bohème c'est la fête des carmen voilà
quelques minutes avant la scène carmen
il y aurait eu ce dernier rendez vous
est ce soir avec l'information
c'est-à-dire le dernier journal que vous
présentera jean cau de la nyc vers 23h40
et puis demain thème de midi en direct
de signes est dire le festival jazz et
recevra 10 eaglets bonsoir à demain 20
heures